I'm gonna browse money I have a special
announcement to make
have you guys heard of your markiplier
oh I'll buy the cinnamon toast Ken I'm a
little too close to the camera I'm sorry
Ken markiplier and Nova and I are
finally gonna see who's the best gamer
on YouTube
cuz it's obviously one of us I'm just
kidding we're gonna battle each other
but it's actually for a good cause
best fiends the gaming app has announced
a tournament where we'll all play
against each other for one week and the
winner gets to donate twenty five
thousand dollars to a charity of
whichever we want so that's pretty
awesome
plus another twenty five thousand
dollars to malaria no more will be
donated to the winner as well the idea
is that we have one week to level up as
much as possible in the game I'll need
you bros help so I have the app ready
and the winner gets to donate to charity
so yes we will battle each other but
it's for a good cause so it's all good
even though they were all [ __ ] down
even though we all know that I'm the
best right it is kind of cheating though
cuz I'm Swedish and we're just superior
in general so I mean you know it's
alright but yeah I need your bros help
though download the app it's on the App
Store best fiends I'll link it down
below and I'm gonna tweet out during the
week and you're just gonna have to have
the app ready to help us out
Meowth Meowth don't help the others they
don't need help
oh yeah I'm very excited for this it's
for a great cause and we get finally get
to prove that I'm the best I'm just
joking I'm probably gonna get my ass
handed to me my ass has been handed to
me so many times I don't even have one
anymore that's what it's really like to
be Swedish Swedish the assless race
that's what they used to call us but now
I'm just getting off to track oh yeah
check out the app it's really fun game
and we'll have some fun and we'll do it
for a great cause I'm very excited
breaths I hope you are as well
hello that was really weird I
brofist all right press as a final
notice here's the videos of the other
contestants we have cinema chose Ken
Oprah hacks renova Kouta and markiplier
who will win me of course that was a
trick question
this should be an exciting competition
stay tuned for more info bras